[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zur heutigen sendung finden nach
dem tod der schlagzeilen macht gleich
diskutieren wir hier am tisch die frage
warum srg chef miller eigentlich noch im
amt das wird aber nicht das einzige
thema bleiben über dass wir
leidenschaftlich debattiert meine gäste
heute abend sind bemerkenswert ist sind
die international gefragte
finanzexpertin sandra gini die auf n-tv
regelmässig erklärt wie die usa schicken
der wirtschaftswoche erklärte sie in den
usa konnte ihren falten mehr als in
deutschland neben joris philip remy er
ist dokumentarfilm regisseur und autor
vor allem zu zeitgeschichtlichen themen
wie der zeit des nationalsozialismus an
meiner seite bild meinung chef philipp
piaggio keiner unserer stammgäste
befinden nach 8 und kaum ein deutscher
journalist beschäftigt sich seit beginn
der pandemie so eingehend mit den
politischen entscheidungen unserer
regierung ich will den jahresurlaub
bezeichnen was erlassen wird neben ihm
alexander kissler hauptstadt
korrespondent der neuen zürcher zeitung
ich habe es ganz gesagt alexander und
einer der klügsten köpfe die unsere
republik zu bieten hat
selbstverständlich hat ja auch
promoviert mein name ist sehr schick und
ich freue mich die sendung eröffnen zu
dürfen schon lange jetzt frage ich die
deutsche corona politik nicht mehr das
wissen die stammzuschauer die regelung
werden immer abstruser die begründungen
immer dürftiger gestern erreichte mich
dann die nachricht einer besorgten
mutter ihre tochter habe einen
sogenannten bank retten von der lehrerin
erhalten ich zeige ihnen hier auch mal
in die kamera die erste frage auf dem
briefbogen warst hast du falsch gemacht
den zweite frage folgende regel habe ich
nicht eingehalten ich habe nicht immer
meine maske auf gehabt der denkzettel
endet mit der frage was nimmst du dir
für die nächste zeit vor die antwort des
kleinen mädchens ich werde jetzt immer
meine maske aufsetzt die schriftliche
benachrichtigung muss von den eltern
unterzeichnet werden ich habe selbst
keine kinder aber ich wünsche mir für
unser land viele eltern die denkzettel
dieser art nicht akzeptieren die nicht
akzeptieren wenn kinder vielleicht mal
beim spielen kurz vergessen ihre masken
nicht auf zu setzen solche art
denkzettel mit nach hause ja ich habe
diesen denkzettel dann auch im internet
gesehen ich dachte im erste photoshop
arbeit so was kann es eigentlich nicht
geben man sieht ja oft irgendwelche
erklärungen die amtlich daher kommen da
macht sich einen spaß daraus und seine
verschwörungs mieten zu züchten das ist
offenbar authentisch das ist authentisch
und das ist leider die rückkehr einer
eigenschaft eine haltung die wir
überwunden glaubt nämlich der schwarzen
pädagogik das sind also kindern angst
macht dass man ihnen ein falsches
verhalten vorwirft das ist ein richtiges
verhalten mit hohem moralischen druck
ich möchte schon sagen adressiert an sie
also interessiert sie dressiert
gewissermaßen zu einem richtigen
verhalten das finde ich sehr sehr
bedauerlich und das zeigt eben dass wir
aus einem politischen virus auch eine
politische verhaltens lehre gemacht
haben ich würde sagen eine verhaltens
lehre der kälte und ich kann nur sagen
ein großes wort das wir im munde führen
dass zivilcourage sagen wir dass und
wissen gleich so recht was wir meinen
ich glaube hier wirklich zivilcourage
gefordert dass wir sagen also ich lasse
meine kinder nicht so abrichten und ich
bin auch nicht bereit meine kinder so
ablichten zu lassen wir sagen sonst
immer mündiger bürger müssen entstehen
ich glaube wenn man solche öffentliche
bus und besserung rituale macht entsteht
ein untertan kein mündiger bürger unter
braucht mündige bürger ich finde das
spannend dass es ja gar keine verordnung
oder kein gesetz gibt das schulen
vorschreibt dass sie solche denkzettel
zu verteilen haben sondern sie kommen
von alleine auf die idee ich glaube
ehrlich gesagt aber nicht dass es ganz
von alleine kommt sondern das ist schon
die also man macht er aus politischer
rhetorik macht man gelebte realität und
was wir in den vergangenen zwei jahren
erlebt haben zunächst relativ lange
unter der bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
und kanzleramtschef helge braun die ja
formal gar nicht zu bestimmen hatten was
in unseren schulen los ist aber wir
haben eine wie ich sage nur die
kinderfeindliche politik erlebt da wurde
angst geschürt da wurde immer wieder
gesagt dass kinder anstecken sind dass
man kinder beschützen muss dass kinder
auch ihre großeltern beschützen müssen
christian drosten hat das damals in
einer umstrittenen studie auch einmal
davor gewarnt schulen zu öffnen und ich
glaube das spiegelt sich dann wieder in
solchen handlungen die gar nicht von
oben verordnet wurden aber man hat das
was zwischen den zeilen durch kann dann
doch ganz gut fertig sage ich noch
schlimmer dann wenn es gar keine
anweisung mehr bleibt wenn es menschen
zu verinnerlichen weil sie meinen sie
machen ein staatsbürgerliche wertvolles
werk ja ich kann man das lehrerbild
tiefer hängen ich meins haben sie ein
titel von einer lehrerin im moment ich
hab's vergessen auch auf twitter
geteilten denkzettel musste übrigens
hier wen ich habe ja mit der mutter aus
gebiet geschrieben von dem mädchen das
ihn bekommen hat und sie hat gesagt
eigentlich versteht sie sich auch sehr
gut mit der lehrerin also dass sie hätte
sie jetzt gewundert aber die lehrerin
wir eigentlich gut aber es hat twitter
kommentare geregnet harry von müttern
von vätern aber auch von erwachsenen die
erzählen was sie eigentlich gerade
erleben und beispielsweise war einst
weder kommentar ich kann natürlich nicht
jeden dieser twitter kommentare
überprüfen wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal
an dass die menschen dort auf twitter
die wahrheit sagen mein sohn hat zwei
wochen eine 4 bekommen und eintrag ins
hausaufgabenheft weil er die maske im
unterricht zweimal abgenommen hat dann
gab es andere kommentare wo ein junger
geschrieben hat bei mir haben meine
eltern also in einer aus der oberstufe
bei mir haben die eltern gar nichts mehr
bekommen wir wurden einfach von der
schule abgeholt und deswegen ich glaube
schon dass dieser denkzettel
wir haben jetzt hier natürlich nur ein
zugespielt bekommen aber dass diese
regelung der maske im unterricht zu
tragen und dann der maßregelung der
schüler ich glaube schon dass er an
mehreren schulen einzug gehalten hat
wenn ich mir die twitter kommentare
gestern durchgelesen habe am ursprung
steht auch eine regierung die erst mal
entscheidet kinder müssen masken tragen
und dann sind so lehrer die sind
möglicherweise auch mit so einer sache
überfordert weil es ja gar nicht so
leicht ist auch kindern zu erklären
diese maske ist auch mir so wahnsinnig
lästig wie nur was ja ich habe immer das
gefühl ich hatte meinen eigenen
schlechten atmen und wenn ich knoblauch
am vorabend gegessen haben dann ist es
wirklich mörderisch und insofern ich
habe ein es ist mühsam ich bin völlig
ihrer meinung ja aber ich frage mich
immer ob man nicht mit dem urteil über
die einzelnen menschen und auch ihr
fehlverhalten oder auch ihre
überreaktion etwas zu hart ist in
angesicht möglicherweise eines kurses
die man kritisieren muss das ist einfach
sie sind historiker sie schon agenda
dann ob es aufs große ganze wenn sie und
die deutsche schulpolitik die die
kinderpolitik sehen und hier wurden dort
kinder ja immer in den fokus der debatte
gestellt wurden schulen viel länger
geschlossen als in anderen ländern wie
ordnen sie das ein warum gerade in
deutschland also ich habe mich mein
leben lang als journalist mit geschichte
beschäftigt und kann mit historikern in
meinen themen auf einer augenhöhe
diskutieren ich bin kein historiker aber
das macht gar nichts wenn ich auf die
sache schaue
ob der fehler von der regierung gemacht
wurden und dann nicht das können sie
wesentlich besser beurteilen als ich und
natürlich wünscht sich jeder dass man
den kindern ihre freiheit zurückgibt
dass die ohne masken in den schulklassen
auch bei geschlossenen fenstern bei den
temperaturen sitzen können das ist
völlig klar und dagegen kann man
argumentieren ich finde bloß dass die
einzelnen mit all diesen anforderungen
manchmal es einfach überfordert sind
auch busfahrer oder vor allem auch ich
sag mal restaurantbesitzer ich selber
habe das erlebt dass ich mit einem
freund in einem restaurant kam er war
nicht geimpft ich war geimpften wir
mussten gehen wieder obwohl es eine
beize war wie wir in bayern sagen dazu
in die wir seit 50 jahren gehen und das
ist dem wird doch auch nicht leicht
gefallen aber ist das nicht dass das das
portale dass der staat selbst nicht in
der lage ist seine regeln zu überprüfen
und sie die kontrolle deshalb den
bürgern überträgt den wirken den lehrern
den busfahrern dass sie sich wie masken
pflicht und impf nachweise kümmern finde
ich nicht so fatal weil ich wusste nicht
wie sie das anders umsetzbar sein soll
also wenn man ein teil könnte man sagen
einfach gar nicht vielleicht ja ein
bisschen regel nicht verkehrt auf ich
bin sehr bei ihnen über die regeln und
die und die notwendigkeit könnten wir
wahrscheinlich stundenlang telefonieren
das gut diskutieren ja aber aber dass
die einzelnen davor recht schwierige
herausforderung gestellt werden und
wissen sie wenn die polizei in bayern
zum beispiel sich ein wird greift der
leute bei sich sitzen hat die
beispielsweise nicht geimpft sind oder
an falschen impfnachweis gebracht haben
und nicht der ausweis übereinstimmen der
macht sein laden zu aber hier geht es ja
nicht um befolgung von regeln sondern
hat er einen ganz hohen moralischen
überschüssen das finde ich einfach so
bedenklich dass man einfach nicht in
einklang junge oder mädchen sagt hör mal
so und so ist es dann müssen wir
irgendwie umgehen dass versuche sie zu
erklären sollen dass das wirklich in die
ecke gestellt wird es wirklich
gewissermaßen mit der foris gesprochen
schämen für ein fehlverhalten
er hat gewissermaßen schande über die
klassengemeinschaft gebracht also das
finde ich einfach viel zu hart und denkt
sein das hat er was von kopflos also man
gibt dir kleinkindern kopfnüsse da bin
ich schon mal beim stichwort schon eben
das ist schwarze pädagogik das hat im 16
jahrhundert nichts verloren wir hätten
letzt ist ja auch ein fall darum haben
wir auch bei bild berichtet er wurde in
einem berufskolleg den den den
erwachsenen schülern dort an mitgegeben
dass sie bitte mützen schals jacken
mitbringen wenn sie mögen auch decken um
die kälte im klassenraum aus zu ertragen
das ich glaube ich dass die
klassenzimmer jetzt ist ja auch bei bild
genannt ich muss auch sagen ich wäre
hier auch bei philips es mir auch gar
nicht so weit gehen müsste als lehrer
aber wie würden sie es einschätzen frau
navidi unsere diskussion wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass wir alle mündige bürger
sind dann würde ich sagen muss jeder die
motivation haben dazu beizutragen zur
bekämpfung der pandemie denn wir können
sie nur als kollektiv bewältigen und ich
bin auch bei herrn remy dass ich denke
dass lehrer manchmal überfordert sind
ist es sicherlich nicht einfach eine
klasse von kleinkindern die sehr
lebendig sind da in sagt man in form zu
halten und in amerika haben wir das
gleiche problem mit den kindern auch und
auch immer das jetzt gerade wo
umgekommen kommt was ja extrem
ansteckend ist dass dann die schulen das
hat sich so verbreitet dass die schule
im endeffekt wieder zugemacht werden
musste und dass viele lehrer auch selbst
angst hatten krank zu werden oder dass
nach hause zu bringen also ich glaube
wir sollten anstatt auch hart dann mit
den lehrern zu urteilen auch mehr
verständnis für die anderen aufbringen
ich muss sagen ich habe ein bisschen mit
der lehrer gemeinschaft natürlich kenne
ich persönlich jetzt nicht hunderte oder
tausende lehrer jeder lehrer sieht das
ja auch sicher unterschiedlich aber was
ich von dem lehrer verbänden und
gewerkschaften mitbekommen habe war ganz
oft er der ton lasst uns lieber im
zweifel dichtmachen im zweifel die
schule schließen das konnte ich am
anfang der pandemie noch nachvollziehen
im laufe der pandemie im ersten herbst
habe ich mir gedacht na ja man weiß
mittlerweile dass kinder nicht so
ansteckend sind und selbst auch nicht
gefährdet sind und die lehrer können ja
auch maske tragen und lüften und aber es
ist spätestens seit der impfung habe ich
überhaupt kein verständnis dafür weil
jeder lehrer der möchte kann sich
doppelt und dreifach bald vielleicht
sogar vierfach impfung ist dann bestens
vor dem virus geschützt und dann hatte
er glaube ich seine arbeit nachzugehen
und seine arbeit ist eigentlich mehr als
normale arbeit ist einberufung dass es
heißt kinder zu auch mit zu erziehen
kindern wissen mitzubringen kindern
mündige bürger zu machen und dann im
zweifel in die schulen zu zu machen
ich habe mein amerika genau das gleiche
problem wo in chicago lehrer gesagt
haben wir weigern uns jetzt physischen
unterricht zu machen ich glaube dass
zwei drei wochen her und die regierung
gesagt hat ihr müsst jetzt in die schule
gehen sonst werdet ihr nicht bezahlt und
in new york hatten wir den fall dass
hunderte schüler aus den schulen
gegangen sind sie wollten wiederum einen
fernunterricht haben also ich glaube um
ikon ist ja trotzdem noch sehr
ansteckend wir sehen immer noch
dramatische fälle und ich glaube auch
die ängste der menschen müssen wir ernst
nehmen und da jetzt brachial durch zu
reagieren und sagen okay ich bin jetzt
ich bin stark ich kann das risiko tragen
es gibt aber mit menschen die das eben
nicht sind und ich würde denen er mit
verständnis begegnen aber ich finde eben
gerade so eine ansprache brachial das
finde ich brachial dass man wirklich
gewissermaßen einen bogen einen zensuren
bogen verteilt und dann sollte an der
oder diejenige sein schlechtes verhalten
eingestehen ich finde das müsste man
wirklich kommunikativ gestehen man kann
auch mit kindern reden aber der als haus
dem kind als hausaufgabe das mit zu
geben dann muss die mutter noch
unterzeichnen dass das kind
gewissermaßen moralisch gefehlt hat das
finde ich nicht wir haben ja auch andere
fälle zwar später amerika wärme zum
beispiel auch england ich war am
wochenende in england da ist die masken
pflicht komplett weg ich musste selbst
am flughafen keine masken tragen auch
nicht bei der passagierkontrolle mehr
ich habe gar keine maske getragen ganze
woche lang und das war dort auch völlig
normal
da durfte jeder mensch einfach selber
entscheiden wie er sich frei da manche
menschen nochmals gegen tragen andere
nicht mich hat er sehr berührt dass
plötzlich wieder die individuelle
entscheidung einen wert hatte weil weder
die mit maske wurden komisch angeguckt
im supermarkt in london noch die ohne
dänemark hat ja heute auch die maßnahmen
fallen lassen aber das gute ist ja
philipp wir bleiben bei der pandemie du
hast nämlich auch ein thema mitgebracht
was sehr passend dazu ist ganz genau und
zwar stelle ich mir die frage warum ist
eigentlich der präsident des robert koch
instituts lothar wieler noch im amt
schauen wir uns einfach mal die
vergangenen mittlerweile zwei monate am
anfang dezember da sagte lothar wieler
voraus in den nächsten wochen werden die
belegung auf den intensivstationen
mitbewohner patienten immer weiter
ansteigen deshalb müssen wir diesen
knallharten kurs verteidigen nur wenige
tage später reichte die intensiv
belegungen ihren höhepunkt seitdem
fallen die zahlen konstant erhält also
die trendumkehr der del-tabelle komplett
verpasst wenige tage später da hatte der
expertenrat gerade ist eine
stellungnahme abgegeben auch mit
gezeichnet von lothar wieler und empfahl
den politikern keine neuen maßnahmen zu
finden hinwil erreichte das nicht am tag
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
veröffentlichte er sein eigenes papier
und forderte den ultimativen lockdown
damit überraschte er sogar karl
lauterbach und bundeskanzler urlaub
scholz und jetzt der nächste große
patzer den haben wir vor zwei wochen
gesehen die eigenmächtige über nacht
verkürzung des genesenen status
wissenschaftlich nicht ansatzweise
belegt von sechs monaten auf drei monate
dazu hat sich lothar wieler zwei wochen
lang nicht einmal erklärt während
hunderttausende bürger sich fragen
musste ob sie eigentlich noch ins
restaurant dürfen ob sie ohne test wo es
und bahn fahren können ich würde sagen
es ist irgendwann die grenze erreicht
karl lauterbach gesundheitsminister ist
ja frisch im amt er muss auch nicht
jeder altlast mitschleppen deswegen
würde ich sagen danke lothar wieler
danke für ihre harte arbeit in dieser
pandemie sie hat sich wirklich
aufgeopfert für dieses land für die
pandemie bekämpfung auch wenn man ihn
nicht allem zustimmen muss hat er das
zweifellos getan aber irgendwann ist
auch mal gut
weil er wie würden sie das einschätzen
mit heavy
naja das ist natürlich immer sehr leicht
die menschen zu kritisieren die da die
entscheidungen fällen müssen wir müssen
sie in omikron ist ja plötzlich aus dem
nichts gekommen anfang dezember und hat
das ganze geschehen wieder dynamisch
beflügelt und wieder eine ganz andere
richtung gebracht die wir vorher noch
gar nicht auf dem radar hatten von daher
sind sicherlich fehler gemacht worden
die sind auch ärgerlich da lagen wir zum
teil ja auch sind wir persönlich
betroffen aber es ist ja auch das
phänomen wenn starke warnungen
ausgesprochen werden und alle ihr
verhalten anpassen dann tritt eben
dieses schlimmste szenario nicht ein das
heißt es nur win situation für die
wissenschaftler und eben auch in amerika
sehen wir das gleiche und ich glaube ist
es den sagen wir ratsamer vorsichtiger
zu sein etwas als zu leichtfertig damit
umzugehen weil ich bin ja für die
wirtschaft zuständig die schlimmste
variante was uns passieren könnte was
nicht ausgeschlossen ist okay
bestenfalls bekommen wir eine n de mi
das wäre fantastisch alles flacht
langsam ab aber es ist eben nicht
ausgeschlossen dass wir eine variante
bekommen die so ansteckend dass wie
mikron aber so tödlich zum beispiel die
saas also jedenfalls wesentlich
tödlicher was machen wir dann also ich
glaube dieser vorsichtige kurs ist schon
ganz gut ich meine der vorwurf von ihnen
galt jetzt ja auch da hat uns alle
überrascht diese handstreichartig
verkürzung des genesenen status von
sechs auf drei monate das finde ich auch
völlig daneben greift der grundrechte
ein mann hat vielleicht von heute auf
morgen keine bewegung sind keine
berufsfreiheit mehr formal allerdings
muss man natürlich sagen war das korrekt
bundestag und bundesrat haben
gewissermaßen dem rk eckhard büsch
gegeben jetzt gab es eine ausarbeitung
der wissenschaftlichen dienste dass die
das kritisiert haben aber auch wir
exklusiv veröffentlicht genau wie schön
dass sie sagen genau die hat jetzt seid
doch nochmal bild wählte den vier
buchstaben ich genau ich dachte mir okay
auf jeden fall bundestag und bundesrat
haben das heft des handelns demokratisch
legitim formal korrekt aus der hand
gegeben haben gewissermaßen gesagt es
gilt das was in der excel-tabelle beim
rk ii steht wenn er das wissen wollt
schaut doch bitte danach ist ruhe dann
einige zurück die fdp sagt ja müsste der
bundestag wieder behandeln da kann ich
nur sagen wie kann so etwas geschehen
wie kann ich so eine wichtige
entscheidung an der eingriffe in die
grundrechte hängen an eine dynamische
excel-tabelle des rk ii aus delegieren
das verstehe ich nicht absolut ehrlich
gesagt ich glaube die waren einfach die
haben nicht gewusst was da kommen kann
es ist natürlich rücklicht wirklich
verteidigte total perplex als ich
gesehen habe welche vollmachten der
bieler plötzlich hat aber karl
lauterbach hat der ministerpräsident nun
mal versprochen an dem tag an dem das ja
durchgesetzt wurde ihr werdet alle
rechtzeitig informiert ihr werdet
benachrichtigt ihr könnt einwände äußern
wir diskutieren das mit euch da wird
nichts einfach so über nacht passieren
da kannte er offenbar seinen lkw
schlecht der hatte offenbar alles schon
vorbereitet per mausklick wurde der
genesenden status damit die grundrechte
von hunderttausenden menschen
zurückgesetzt ob ihr dürft warum sitzt
ja nicht hier der wille auf meinem platz
zum beispiel sie stellen die fragen es
würde mich interessieren wie er reagiert
sehr so wahnsinnig schwer von außen zu
beurteilen was ist jetzt da erklärbar
was mich da ich wünschte er würde hier
sitzen wir haben regelmäßig
interviewanfragen an herrn bieler
geschickt bislang nie mit positive
rückmeldung ich meine die frage die sie
gestellt haben wir warum noch im amt
lauterbach ist natürlich der vorgesetzte
der behördenleiter mir nicht ein
tierarzt auch herr bieler meiner böse
vermutung ist ja es ist gewissermaßen
die vorratshaltung eines sündenbocks
also wer weiß was da noch kommen mag und
dann kann man jemand jetzt schon mal ein
bisschen an die kandare nehmen und sagen
wir mal freundlichen das war dein
letzter fehlschuss jetzt ist ja ganz
ganz enge führung sozusagen und wenn
doch mal etwas passiert dann kann ich
sagen ja ich habe ihn noch eine chance
gegeben und kann ein gewissermaßen die
sündenbock funktionen bei herren wieder
zu einem womöglich noch dramatischeren
zeitpunkt abladen absolut ich glaube
dass das der einzige grund warum karl
lauterbach ihnen nicht gehen lässt außer
beim genesenen status da hat es mich
gewundert dass er sich so vor ihn
gestellt hat also hat sich wirklich mit
der entscheidung gemein gemacht und hat
gesagt dass es wissenschaftlich
hervorragend begründet kommunikativ war
das vielleicht alles nicht so optimal
und dann kam ein wissenschaftler nach
dem anderen ich persönlich kann das ja
gar nicht beurteilen aber wenn carsten
wachsen will hendrik strikt kommen wenn
sogar sandra diese kommt die eigentlich
nicht bekanntes dafür dass die äußerst
regierungskritische sondern sie ist ein
regierungsberater und auch immer gewesen
und sagen das ist falsch gelesen das
sind genau so gut geschützt dann stimmt
ja nicht mal die wissenschaftliche basis
der arbeit des robert koch instituts und
dann weiß ich überhaupt nicht worüber
wir sprechen das natürlich generell die
gefahr beim robert-koch-institut dass
man sich einen automatismus der
permanenten legitimation hinein gegeben
hat also man hat das gewissermaßen
gesagt das was regierungspolitik ist
beruht auf wissenschaftlicher expertise
und die wird gewissermaßen ausgegeben
oder zertifiziert vom robert koch
institut das in unsere leute das sind
unsere leute man wird also jetzt auch
einen rückwirkenden strich durch die
bisherige pandemie politik ziehen wenn
man sagen würde ja auf einmal ist das
nicht mehr so ganz wissenschaftlich hoch
exzellent was das lka ihr anbietet weil
ich gerne spannend findet um nochmal den
punkt von frau navidi einer aufzufangen
und weiter zu spinnen auch sehr gesagt
vorsicht ist dann besser ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich bin es leid dass die
vor sichtweiten gelassen wird wenn ich
die zahlen sehe der selbstmordrate bei
kindern die gestiegen ist wenn ich die
zahlen sehe und das muss man einfach
wirklich sagen wir haben einen sehr
hohen preis gezahlt in der pandemie und
den zahlen wir immer immer immer weiter
und ich muss wirklich sagen wenn wir
weiterhin immer wieder die vorsicht
first machen ich kann beispielsweise
meinen job ausüben ich bin nicht so
stark davon betroffen aber wenn man
beispielsweise auch in restaurants geht
die haben auch stark gelitten also wenn
man in die in die innenstädte geht da
sind auch viele lehnen die dicht machen
sehen wir eben gesagt sie sind ja auch
dafür die wirtschaft entsprechen über
die wirtschaft ich glaube dass vor allem
auch die vorsicht nehmen wir jetzt mal
die 2g plus regel nur als eine regel wo
ja vorsicht besser als nachsicht ist
anders könnte man sie ja nicht erklären
die außengastronomie beispielsweise ich
kann nur meine heimatstadt sprechen er
wurde jetzt auch außengastronomie
aufgebaut und heizstrahler um es auch
mal ein bisschen ab zu viel einsatz den
umsatzverlust der letzten monate und ja
auch bei die jahre der darf nicht mehr
in der außengastronomie draußen ein
jemand sitzen denn nur zwei impfungen
hat und nicht sein schnell dass an dem
tag mit hut und ich finde mittlerweile
dass man wirklich mal sagen muss das ist
doch reicht man kann oder verstehen sie
alle regelungen als bürgerin also mir
geht es wirklich langsam so ich habe
einfach keine lust mehr weil ich vieles
nicht mehr verstehe und ich auch viele
ist als die sanierung auf fasse
mittlerweile ja das mag ja so sein aber
wenn sie sagen ich bin es leid das ist
eigentlich relativ irrelevant weil es
dem virus egal ist denn die rot des
virus ist sie noch nicht leid und es
besteht eben große gefahr und wenn wir
nicht vorsichtig sind dann werden die
menschen sich zurückziehen da sagen wir
mal die ansteckungsraten nehmen zu der
staat macht veranlasst keine maßnahmen
dann werden die leute trotzdem zu hause
bleiben sie werden nicht so viel
konsumieren sie werden eh nicht den
restaurants gehen von daher macht es
sinn kollektiv zu versuchen diese
krankheit in den griff zu bekommen ist
wir haben also als im gegensatz zu mir
immer noch die meinung in deutschland
dass jede einzelne maßnahme zur pandemie
bewältigung hilft nein ich sagte ist ein
dynamisches geschehen und wir müssen
unser verhalten anpassen es werden stets
fehler geschehen wie eben der zettel von
dem lehrer da müssen wir darüber reden
und ich bin mir sicher dass das gerne
zurück genommen wird und in zukunft dann
eben nicht mehr so gemacht wird aber
niemand ist ja für uns alle neu und ja
also ich glaube es besser vorsichtig zu
sein für die wirtschaft tun sie das auch
so harry nach fast zwei jahren pandemie
ich bin ein bisschen anleihe in der
ganzen sache nicht wie ein pirat auf ein
experte und was ich weiß ist ich habe
mich impfen lassen aus selbstschutz das
ist der erste gedanke gewesen und zwar
inklusive boostern ich bin eine freundin
sehr dankbar das für mich ein bisschen
angestoßen hat und war froh dass ich
erst mal raus bin aus der kiste ich habe
nicht das gefühl dass diese impfung
jetzt einfach verhindert dass andere
angesteckt werden sondern so wie es im
augenblick aussieht kann ich mich auch
anstecken und mein gefühl wenn sie mir
ein bisschen kritik erlauben ist
kommunikativ war das ganze nicht erst
seit zwei monaten ein extremes desaster
aber auch politiker sind menschen es ist
eine pandemie wahrscheinlich so wenig
vorhersehbar
selbst wenn es planungsunterlagen gab
zehn jahre vorher schon wie man das
hätte machen müssen dass die leute zum
teil wirklich überfordert waren aber ja
da bin ich ganz bei ihnen ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass viele maßnahmen anders
kommuniziert werden offene die
unsicherheiten auch ehrlicher auf den
tisch gelegt werden ich will nicht
wissen bei der ersten impfung du bist
damit raus aus dem spiel und immer fit
und heiß plötzlich jetzt bauen wir noch
eine zweite und dritte und jetzt schon
klar ich brauche noch eine vierte und
fünfte brauche ich auch ich mache das
auch ich will mich selber schützen das
ist meine persönliche entscheidung weil
ich mache niemand anderem wirklich
niemand anderer entwurf die leute sind
frei sich zu entscheiden wie sie mögen
so war es immer im land und wenn dann
hätte man eine impfpflicht sehr früh
machen müssen aber die person kann man
darüber reden aber es ist so wie es
gelaufen ist ist es glaube ich kein
meisterstück gewesen aber es war auch
eine große herausforderung so ist das
ist so der laie von der straße der ihr
mit will spricht
gut da für sie auch da dass hier alle
miteinander debattieren wir ja wir
erlauben ihn aber jetzt eine kleine
pause von corona und gehen weiter zu
einem anderen wichtigen thema und zwar
dem klima alexander ja es gibt ja wenige
momente in denen ich mich alt fühle aber
ich muss jetzt mal gestehen es gibt
einen moment da fühle ich mich immer alt
dann nämlich wenn ich merke dass keiner
mehr von naturschutz und umweltschutz
spricht sondern auch alle von
klimaschutz ich erkenne an das ist ein
großes problem ist eine wichtige
herausforderung wir dürfen nicht die
augen verschließen ja aber klimaschutz
gibt gibt nicht bloß für sämtliche
eingriffe beispielsweise in den
straßenverkehr wie wir sie diese woche
in hamburg und berlin
sie mussten an 34 tagen mehrere stunden
auf der a 100 auf 310 und anderen
autobahnen war der straßenverkehr
lahmgelegt warum klima aktivisten haben
erklärt was sie immer sagen wir haben
keine zeit mehr wir sind verzweifelt wir
sind die letzte generation und deshalb
legen wir den verkehr lahm ja so nennen
sich diese aktivisten wir sind die
letzte generation das finde ich anmaßend
und unklug apokalyptisch panisch und
auch etwas paranoid es geht immer weiter
wir müssen kreativ umgehen mit der
herausforderung die wir haben auch mit
der klimakrise selbstverständlich aber
das gibt doch kein recht dass wir wie in
früheren zeiten wie eine endzeit sägt
sie davon ausgeht dass morgen die welt
untergeht anderen menschen unseren
pessimismus aufzwingen nein das geht
doch nicht und man tut auch für die
sache keinen guten dienst weil wer von
diesen menschen die bereits für euch
hunde mehrere stunden im stau gestanden
haben vielleicht wichtige termine
verpasst haben beim notar bei der
hochzeit im krankenhaus ein
bewerbungsgespräch wird denn sagen ich
habe gerne im stau gestalten weil ich
dadurch das klima gerettet habe nein das
wird niemand tut deshalb würde ich sagen
liebe aktivisten sei es nun von ende
gelände oder von letzte generation kommt
zurück auf den pfad der vernunft redet
seit aber keine gefahr für den
straßenverkehr und bittet rüstet etwas
moralisch ab heraus aus dem
apokalyptischen schützengräben
das war ein leidenschaftliches plädoyer
da gebe ich direkt mal weiter harry was
sagen sie dazu also ich meine fesselt
fabelhafte also inhaltlich ganz bei
ihnen ich würde die burschen versuchen
von der straße schnell weg zu gehen ja
gewiss aber
meine frage wäre das der
freiheitsberaubung der kissler das doch
das ist auch letztendlich ist es doch
kein legales mittel seiner meinung gehör
zu verschaffen das ist richtiges wegen
werden auch immer die personalien
aufgenommen aber wir haben dann gelesen
von 30 60 leute wurde die personalien
aufgenommen wurden alle wieder
freigelassen einige haben sie nach
gleich wieder hingesetzt das heißt das
schöne wort not kennt kein gebot wird so
gewendet dass man sich nicht an die
regeln des straßenverkehrs und auch an
die bewegungsfreiheit halten muss und
leiter das spiel eben hin zu haben
oftmals solche radikalen klimaaktivisten
den vorteil dass sie von der
öffentlichkeit permanenten
schulterklopfen ausgestattet sind und
deshalb schwindet die kritikfähigkeit
aber wir sind ein rechtsstaat da sind
wir uns doch einig und wenn jemand sich
auf die straße sitzt den verkehr
blockiert menschen davon abhält zur
frühschicht zu haben und ja ich glaube
es sind sogar
rettungssanitäter sprachen von einer
seite aber habe ich auch aufgehalten und
dann ist es doch ein fall für den kadi
und da müssen wir gar nicht reden weil
wir demonstrieren geht darf
demonstrieren gehen und wer sich auf die
straße sitzt der raub den anderen die
zeit und das darf es nicht geben und
berlin ist ein sonderfall das weiß jeder
der sich mit berliner bisher
beschäftigen aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das in münchen mehr als
einmal passieren würde ich glaube da
wird ganz schnell in berlin wollte
niemand zur arbeit aber es gibt einige
von diesen klima aktivisten die sich
wirklich festkleben lassen das ist
wirklich dann haben wir schon an ein
einheit eingängen von banken zum
beispiel macht das wirklich stunden
gedauert hat bis man diese menschen mit
diesem schweren schweren hatten
klebstoff von dem objekt der begierde
also eine tür beispielsweise los
bekommen hat oder man musste sie
losschneiden weil sich angekettet hatten
und da finde ich einfach da fehlt
einfach in der öffentlichkeit auch die
kritik dass man sagt damit desavouiert
ihr euer anliegen und das ist genau die
grenze die wir nicht mehr bereit sind
wir akzeptieren aber sie sagen noch
genau dass das doch fabelhaft und ich
sage dir noch zu das ist heute sich wir
müssen gar nicht groß diskutieren an
meine meinung ist es nicht erlaubt es
ist keine form es ist wahnsinnig
rücksichtslos gegenüber vielen menschen
die sowieso schon im stau stehen es kann
überhaupt nicht sein außerdem ist es
irgendwie nervt es auch dass leute die
in der früh zur arbeit müssen anstehen
die gebirge da hocken und trocknen
welche klima apostel und wollen die
nicht durchlassen bei allem respekt vor
der frage des klimaschutzes ist das ein
schritt zu weit es ist einfach nicht
vorgesehen bei uns man muss ja sagen
polizei hat ja auch einige demonstranten
festgenommen durchweg zu tragen genau
die gegen lebensmittelverschwendung ja
immer genau jetzt haben naja das
grundanliegen ich muss sagen ich bin ja
hier ich bin jetzt wahrscheinlich die
miesmacher in der runde vor allem
aktuell mit blick auf die krone pandemie
und wie immer protestierende da
eigentlich das recht genommen werden
soll ich bin total dafür dass man
demonstrieren kann ich finde das auch
nervig ich würde es auch so aufregen
aber ich bin so stark ich finde im
moment muss fasst das rechte
demonstration mehr geschützt so können
demonstrationen wenn ich keine autobahn
setze ich finde es ist keine
demonstration sind eingriff eine andere
stimmt es kann leben gefährden leben
gefährden wenn jemand aus versehen durch
fällt also ich finde es schon sehr
riskant und ist eben gegensatz zu
anderen dieses anderen demonstrationen
die an der grenze des legalen sind
jenseits dessen wird es hier viel zu
wenig freue mich dass ich mir da
zustimmen da aber es wird viel zu wenig
kritisch diskutiert weil man immer sagt
ja ist aber doch ein wichtiges ergebnis
muss man aber ich behaupte es tut wie
gesagt diesem anliegen nicht gut es wird
überhaupt nichts für den klimaschutz
getan wenn ich zu spät zur arbeit komme
und es wird auch kein was man im
training der lebensmittel auch sehr
genau und es wird auch kein so hoher
moralischer druck aufgebaut man will ja
dadurch herrn scholz und ein habig
bewegen noch schneller aus den fossilen
energie auszusteigen das wird man nicht
der zweck heiligt auch wirklich nicht
die mittel das ist leider ein alter satz
den man in diesem fall zustimmen muss
und man hat allerdings den eindruck wenn
man das richtige ziel schreibt dann ist
auch über seine mittel schreibt dann ist
dieses mittel heute legitimiert oftmals
ich meine es gibt ja verschiedene
auflagen die man einhalten muss die ganz
offensichtlich nie eingehalten wurden
aber die auflage maske und abstand das
ist also das große heiligtum auf
demonstration wenn menschen draußen an
der frischen luft während omikron
ehrlich gesagt sowieso auch einfach mal
durch läuft weil die maßnahmen nicht weg
aber wenn demonstranten draußen die
maske nicht tragen wenn die
demonstration auch pauschal auf
präventiv untersagt
die große politische empörung über diese
demonstration habe ich jetzt nicht
gesehen und ich muss sagen ich bin da
auch bei dir eigentlich gar nicht
menschen wirklich gerade jetzt dass sie
demonstrieren wo sie wollen auf der
anderen seite denke ich mir mein gott
man kann auch einfach in jeder
innenstadt demonstrieren auf jedem
opernplatz oder sonst wo man muss nicht
auf die autobahn ich hatte in der aus
wie gespalten ich bin da eigentlich
ähnlich wie die unverlangt extremen
zwiegespalten grenze ist eben offen zur
gewaltanwendung ich hatte neulich ein
streitgespräch im radio mit einem klima
aktivisten und er sagt wortwörtlich wenn
es keinen klimaschutz gibt gibt es bald
auf die mütze und das ist natürlich dann
an eine sprache die enthemmt ist und da
müssen wir schon aufpassen also ob es
egal für klimaschutz oder für andere
anlegen wenn ich und auch verbal nur sei
dahingestellt zugestanden verbal nur mit
auf die mütze geben als mit
gewaltanwendung weil ich eben meine ich
habe das recht dazu weil über morgen die
welt untergeht dann überschreite ich
genau diese grenzen des zivilen
vernünftigen erwachsenen diskurses an
dem ich ja teilnehmen möchte freunde wie
die gießener usa hieß das
demonstrationsrecht dort oder gehen dort
die menschen die straße ist ein sehr
sensibles thema nach black lifes maria
also die menschenrechts proteste gegen
die rechtsverletzungen der schwarzen vor
allen dingen auch weil sich dort immer
wieder auch kriminelle darunter gemischt
haben und der die legitimen protestler
und geplündert haben und also auch in
manhattan in der nähe von meinem
wohngebiet ladenlokale sind eingebrochen
sie haben vorher gelegt das war schon
ziemlich schockierend was da passiert
ist deswegen ich glaube dass so
exzessive also das recht auf protest ist
enorm wichtig da bin ich völlig bei
ihnen ich glaube dass wenn man gegen
recht und gesetz verstößt man sich das
den missmut dem mitbürger wie sagt man
auf sich zieht und das ist dann
kontraproduktiv ist darauf eingerichtet
demonstrieren unter corona bedingungen
man darf ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht so sicher ich glaube das kommt
dann auch auf den staat darauf wann ich
weiß noch dass donald trump eine seiner
ersten amtshandlungen war das recht zu
demonstrieren wollte er einschränken ob
wohl wissend wahrscheinlich was denn da
kommen würde also deswegen ich glaube
als grundrecht ist das ganz ganz wichtig
dass man auf die straße gehen darf
natürlich es geht unter wenn man einfach
nur so als graue masse daher kommt man
die aufmerksamkeit durch kontroverse
aktionen auf sich ziehen kann und damit
hervorstechen kann und damit
medienberichterstattung bekommen kann
das hat es immer gegeben den 68ern es
wird auch wahrscheinlich immer geben das
stimmt was macht eigentlich freilich for
future gerade habe ich mich gefragt die
sind hier nicht ganz so radikal aber ich
merke vielleicht ist das bin ich einfach
im absoluten corinna tunnel hierbei bild
aber ich habe mir das gefühl seit
monaten nichts mehr von facebook user
gehört was macht man irgendwie etwas
eingeschlafen vor zwei wochen habe ich
gelesen es geht wieder los da war aber
auch schlechtes wetter und dann merkt
man gleich dass die teilnehmerzahlen
erodieren dann kam monique und dank
haben migranten genau aber es ist eben
genau natürlich ist freiheit ist für
fischer ist nicht in einzusetzen mit
sowas aber auch dort haben natürlich
töne die also der der radikalität das
wort reden auch frau frau neubauer sagt
wir brauchen einen radikalen klimaschutz
gut kann ich sagen ist eine metapher nur
in anderen bereichen heißt es immer auch
von unserer innenministerin radikal geht
gar nicht mehr also ein radikaler
klimaschutz ist ein offenbar legitimen
teilweise gewünscht ein radikaler
einsatz für was anderes ist nicht so
gewünscht also ich finde bei radikalität
muss man immer vorsichtig sein und erst
mal sagen oh was ist denn da gemeint und
nicht sagen weil es für den klimaschutz
ist gibt so eine art von guter
radikalität ich würde auf jeden fall
sagen diese proteste auch darüber zu
reden sie zu bewerten ist eine sehr gute
übung weil ich merke ja auch aus dem
politischen lager dass mir vielleicht
mehr steht das dass ich irgendwie als
liberal bezeichnen würde dass sobald
beispielsweise für klimaschutz
protestiert wird dadurch gewisse
befindlichkeiten sind dass man das denen
nicht so ganz gut und ich glaube das ist
eigentlich ganz gute übung um aushalten
klar auf die autobahn setzen geht nicht
aber ansonsten können wir den menschen
das demonstrieren aushalten von
meinungen oder auch von protesten finde
ich ein gutes jahr zwischen volt in den
games ganz kurz ab in eine mini
unterbrechen und sind dann auch sofort
wieder zurück in zwei noch sehr
spannenden themen bis gleich
[Musik]
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren viertel nach acht geben der
schlagend sein machen mein name fehler
[Musik]
so nicht red bull herr jörges hätten das
auto ist aber niemand um den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darm führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zu überlassen lasst den leuten den
spaß wir sehen da etwas was eigentlich
fatale ist in der politik bei den
journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu führen
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
dürfte sein dass italien eine party zum
manko vielleicht einmal kurz an dann
werden wir ganz nennen doch das ist
übliche an dem radträger aus
ich hab mein beispiel meine sache immer
bekommt er kümmert sich darum niemand
gibt es bargeld
man muss ja ganz kleine auch darüber
sprechen ganz klein sagt nicht fertig
richtig ist die komödie nicht begraben
nur noch 40
[Musik]
wir sind auch direkt schon wieder zurück
und wir wollen keine zeit fliegen es
geht weiter mit dem thema von der regel
der januar war wieder ein monat des
gedenkens an den holocaust zwanzigster
januar die wannseekonferenz mit diesem
sensationellen remake das im fertigen
aufgeführt wurde dann der 27 januar
befreiung von auschwitz die politiker
die mit den schildern remember in der
hand sich vor dem bundestag haben
ablichten lassen das ist alles gut das
ist wichtig und trotzdem habe ich das
gefühl dass unser gedenken zwar immer
mehr wird aber immer wirkungsloser wird
warum weil nicht der meinung sind dass
in der gesellschaft ein ganzer bereich
von antisemitismus irgendwie nicht
ernsthaft eingeordnet wird ich will ein
paar beispiele geben zum beispiel ist es
in mode gekommen ist sich ja gut wenn
man an die verbrechen der kolonialzeit
erinnert an die deutschen verbrechen
beispielsweise in namibia die mord an
den herero und nama trotzdem habe ich
das gefühl dass an manchen stellen die
kolonialen verbrechen missbraucht werden
um den holocaust zu relativieren
und das ist nicht nur mein gefühl
sondern das deutet sich auch einfach an
dann haben wir eine überspitzte
israelkritik im land es gibt nur ein
einziges land auf der welt das das wort
israel kritik als begriff
aufgestellt hat das heißt nicht denn wir
haben nicht china kritik oder türkei
kritik obwohl es jeden grund gäbe diese
länder für ihre politischen zustände zu
kritisieren aber ausgerechnet
deutschland in dem sechs millionen juden
ermordet wurden leistet sich den luxus
israelkritik zum zugang zur weit
verbreiteten zu einer art massensport zu
machen zum teil geht das so weit dass
dem land sogar das existenzrecht
abgesprochen wird in milderer form wird
zum boykott maßnahmen gegen israelische
waren aufgerufen das alles vor dem
hintergrund von auschwitz ist für mich
unfassbar und schließlich und endlich
haben wir einen ganzen bereich von
antisemitismus zum teil während
ausschreibungen von muslimischen bürgern
gegen juden in deutschland der von einem
teil der gesellschaft nicht thematisiert
wird der weg geblendet ausgeblendet wird
da wird weggeschaut und wir es anspricht
den wirft man vorher du bist ein rassist
oder islamophobie oder ich weiß nicht
was und das problem es währenddessen wir
bei rechter rechtsextremer hetze bei
antisemitismus aus dem rechten spektrum
beispielsweise höcker mit seinem denkmal
der schande ganz zu recht ein
proteststurm im ganzen land haben wird
über diese etwas wirren thesen
kolonialismus versus holocaust
israelkritik
wegschauen bei muslimischen
antisemitismus der wird auf akademischem
niveau diskutiert das halte ich für
wirklich völlig falsch das muss genauso
hart gebrandmarkt und ausgegrenzt werden
wie der rechte antisemitismus sie haben
das so treffend analysiert aber eine
frage hätte ich noch versuchen sie es
mal in aller kürze zu sagen woran liegt
das dass ausgerechnet deutschland dass
er zumindest seit 20 jahren 30 ich würde
sagen geradezu professionell gedenkt und
auf das eigene denken ja auch sehr stolz
ist warum kriegt deutschland das nicht
in griff all das was gerade beschrieben
haben was ist da falsch gelaufen also
zum einen fällt auf dass das dass diese
weniger kritisierten
erscheinungsform von antisemitismus
immer aus der linken ecke kommen da ist
sicherlich ein problem da muss einfach
ein umdenken hin niemand der so was
kritisiert ist deswegen gleich rechts ja
das ist so ein spiel was gespielt wird
kritisierst du irgendwas dann wird ja
das vorgeworfen das begann schon im
historikerstreit als es um den ausbruch
des ersten weltkriegs ging da war die
paradoxe situation dass ein ehemaliger
as a man hatte ein buch geschrieben in
dem er dem ersten weltkrieg schon
sozusagen das vorspiel zum zweiten
nannte und die deutsche kriegsschuld für
immer festgeschrieben hat und dann hatte
ein anderer der war im widerstand ein
historiker hat gesagt das ist aber so
schlimm war's nix waren waren er alle
und dann warf der as a man
in dem widerständler vor du bist ja nazi
und dieses spiel haben wir seit 50
jahren für 160 jahren und das muss
aufhören wir müssen antisemitismus
radikal und mit der wurzel ablehnen das
können wir uns in deutschland nicht
leisten ich will das für niemand anders
vorschreiben in der welt aber unser land
ist so belastet in seiner geschichte das
wir leise sein müssten das nicht wir die
sind die auf der straße stehen sowie in
bremen und sagen kauft nicht beim
israeli allein die assoziation die raubt
einem den atem wenn man weiß was damals
passiert ist und deswegen ich glaube da
ist ein problem ist wir müssen aufhören
es ist kein kavaliersdelikt es kann
jeder seine kritik äußern es kann auch
noch so wirre thesen über kolonialismus
geäußert werden das will ich überhaupt
niemand absprechen wir müssen das
genauso ablehnen müssen den mut haben
und nicht plötzlich anfangen akademisch
zu diskutieren könnte es nicht doch sein
dass
dieses wirklich grauenvolle verbrechen
an den herero und nama ist eben doch so
sehr wie der holocaust und so weiter das
ist einfach unfassbar der holocaust ist
unvergleichlich
einzigartigen da gibt es nichts zu
deuteln dran und ich glaube da ist eines
der probleme und das zweite ist auch
erfährt darf ich glaube dass uns dieses
verständnis dieses verbrechens verfolgen
wird noch über generationen weil es so
unfassbar ist und ich glaube das ein
reflex der menschen ist das abzulehnen
das zu bagatellisieren das ist gar nicht
böse gemeint verständnis dass nicht
greifbare konkrete frage glauben sie
dass wir zu wenig über die täter
sprechen
also wir haben uns ja gerade diesen film
wäre ich auch sehr gelungen fahren über
die wannsee-konferenz gesehen das war
ein reines gruselkabinett der täter
insofern hoffe ich schon dass die
erinnerung wachgehalten wird
andererseits gibt es immer wieder
umfragen gerade jetzt eine das eben das
historische wissen an den schulen doch
eben sehr sehr gering ist und man kann
leider nicht davon ausgehen dass man
automatisch gewissermaßen mit der
muttermilch das wissen über diese
verantwortung und diese diese schuld
auch mitbekommt wenn man in einer
multikulturellen gesellschaft sind
müssen wir jeder generation das wieder
uns neu erarbeiten das eine ganz große
pädagogische herausforderung war moment
mal wurde sich das dann überhaupt
gearbeitet wenn das wird es wird es wird
so hoch dass immer darüber gesprochen
dass da etwas verloren gehen können also
ich habe an meiner schule schon gehabt
gut ich habe dann auch geschichte
studiert aber ich hatte auch in meinem
gymnasium war das schon ein wichtiger
punkt aber war das eben ist das unter
nicht dass einer der großen standen der
nachkriegszeit das zu wenig gesprochen
wurde und wenn dann nur zu abstrakt dass
schon die generation der kinder zu
selten gefragt hat so selten zugehört
hat das ist richtig und das geht ja
weiter im grunde genommen müssten wir
uns alle ehrlich machen das heißt uns
stehen die südafrikanischen wahrheit'
unten vielleicht sogar noch bevor jede
gemeinde jede familie wird sich
irgendwann mal ehrlich machen müssen in
hinblick auf die beteiligung sie kennen
diese untersuchung glaube 40 oder 30
prozent der deutschen glauben und
behaupten auch ihre angehörigen hätten
im in derzeit 33 45 widerstand geleistet
und es stimmt aber leider nicht sind
dann irgendwie 23 prozent ich war ihr
habt die genaue prozentzahl nicht im
kopf aber das zeigt schon wir sind über
du musst die sache anschauen niemand ist
schuld ich meine sie haben mir das wort
angesprochen mit der israelkritik wo er
fast gewissermaßen deutschland einen
trade mark drauf hat schändlicher weise
und es gibt ja diesen diesen satz dem in
seiner tiefe glaube ich gar nicht genug
im gar nicht tief genug ermessen kann
form von fortsetzen sind das zentrale
juden herrn schuster israel ist unsere
lebensversicherung und das ist nicht nur
einfach so dahin gesagt das ist ganz
konkret so gemeint unsere
lebensversicherung die brauchen wir wenn
es uns an den kragen gehen sollte und
deshalb verstehe ich auch nach wie vor
nicht dass deutschland teilweise bei
israelkritik mit macht seit es mit einem
ambivalenten abstimmungsverhalten bei
den vereinten nationen beispielsweise
dass man zu wenig auch das wort erhebt
wenn israel ein apartheidstaat genannt
wird also ich glaube man macht sich da
in einem vielleicht linken toleranz
begriff ist zu leicht wenn man sagt ja
es ist ja alles nur eine form des der
kritik die möglich sein muss dies leider
oft über das ziel hinaus israels unser
lebensversicherung ist ein ganz tiefer
setzen da ist gerade kürzlich was
passiert und dass ich gerne ansprechen
würde und ich würde auch gern wissen was
sie davon halten frauen rwd und zwar hat
vor wenigen tagen vielleicht war es auch
erst gestern die berühmte amerikanische
schauspielerin whoopi goldberg die hat
in einer fernsehsendung plötzlich den
satz gesagt holocaust is not about race
im holocaust ging es gar nicht um die
rasse um rassismus sie hat gesagt da hat
verdi eine die tätergruppe war weiß und
die opfergruppe war weiß also die
deutschen und die juden da ging es nur
darum wie grausam der eine mensch zum
anderen sein kann das passt ja doch auch
irgendwo ident in die identitätsdebatte
indem man neu entscheidet wer täter und
wer opfer ist und was rassismus ist und
was nicht wie nehmen sie diese
identitätsdebatte in den usa war er das
hat noch mal eine ganz andere qualität
als in deutschland wo goldberg hat sich
dafür entschuldigt sie hat das falsch
eingeordnet falsch verstanden da spielen
verschiedene kriterien mit rein auch die
das schwarz sein in amerika ist ja auch
ein sehr sensibles thema wie man das
angeht aber der antisemitismus ist bei
uns ja im moment gerade auch ein großes
thema der überwiegend von rechts kommt
und gerade wurde auch der sitz wir
fangen die rechte an sie wollen bücher
verbieten in denen der holocaust
geschildert wird weil das die gefühle
der kinder also und auch der versklavung
zum beispiel also alles was die weiße
geschichte irgendwie was die weißen
schlecht dastehen lassen könnte also da
spielt vieles ineinander mit rein an
vielen verschiedenen ecken nicht was ich
mitbekommen haben dass die abgeordnete
mon chéri taylor green gesagt hat dass
die feuer in kalifornien sein verursacht
worden von
jüdischen finanziers die mit space
lesern das angefragt hätten also da ist
nichts abstrus und abenteuerlich genug
in florida wurden gerade und sechs
anderen staaten wie sagt man zettel
verteilt wo gesagt wurde wo die schuld
für den corona pandemie den juden in die
schuhe geschoben wurde und donald trump
hat ist auch ein bisschen salonfähig
gemacht dass die rechten auf die straße
gehen das war auch vergangene woche in
florida ich habe es noch nicht gewusst
ob meine social media sind videos wenn
man das sieht was sie sagen mittlerweile
offen und auf plakaten tragen das kann
man kaum also es wirklich schwer zu
fassen nur vorsichtig zwei deutsche
zeitungen haben behauptet während der
korona epidemie israel hätte nur die
eigenen jüdischen bürger geimpft und den
palästinensern dass die den impfstoff
vorenthalten nur eine der beiden
zeitungen hatte die eier diese
falschmeldung zurück zu nehmen das ist
nicht fair
nun also man kann ja schon einmal über
diese dokumentation sprechen die es im
öffentlich-rechtlichen gab von format
steuerungen f so hieß das da ging es
genau darum dass die israelis ihre leute
also die juden vermeintlich impfen und
die palästinenser zusagen vom stoff
fernhalten und auch das was natürlich
ein klassisches
antisemitisches motiv was da verbreitet
wurde obwohl erstens in israel 20
prozent der menschen nicht juden sind
selbstverständlich genauso geimpft
wurden und zweitens israel angeboten hat
der palästinensischen autonomiebehörde
impfstoff zu liefern haben die
palästinenser das abgelehnt war der
spiegel und die frankfurter rundschau
und die frankfurter rundschau hat den
mut gehabt dass wenigstens
zurückzunehmen der spiegel hat es nicht
so dass der kollege henning fuchs das
gemachte frankfurt und das finde ich
schon also es tut mir leid und sie haben
völlig recht auf diese ihren
rechtsextremen oder rechtsradikalen in
amerika hinzuweisen wir haben das
problem bei uns eben auch und das
problem ist schaut sich die fratze des
antisemitismus von beiden seiten an das
ist unser problem und wir reden nur über
einem das ist wirklich nicht gut ich
muss jetzt einen harten beruf machen den
ich ehrlich gesagt ungerne mache ich
möchte ich irgendwann bei ihnen gedanken
herum ich finde es ganz wichtig das
thema heute abend mitgebracht haben
vielen dank und wir kommen zu ihm fr wie
die ja also was mir große sorgen
bereiten sind die tech konzerne ihre
übermacht ihre monopolmacht weil sie
vergrößern immer mehr die
wirtschaftliche ungleichheit die
zersetzen die gesellschaft und sie
stellen eine gefahr für die demokratie
dar mit ihren algorithmen und ihren
daten programmieren sie unser gehirn und
unsere verhaltensweisen und sie greifen
immer mehr in unser leben ein zum teil
mehr als regierungen ohne dafür
demokratisch legitimiert zu sein
deswegen plädiere ich für eine
entmachtung und zwar durch eine
verkleinerung durch regulierung
gesetzgebung
aufsicht besteuerung
haftungsvorschriften ja und einiges
andere um die ein bisschen an die leine
zu nehmen sowie die dann habe ich direkt
eine frage sie haben donald trump sehr
hart kritisiert jetzt kritisieren sie
die tech konzerne sehr hart twitter hat
beispielsweise den us-präsidenten dem
ehemaligen us-präsidenten von seiner
plattform verbannt ist das richtig ist
das gesund für eine demokratie ja das
war in diesem fall richtig jetzt kommen
sie aber natürlich direkt mit absoluten
extrem sonderfall das kann man noch mal
separat diskutieren ich würde mich jetzt
mal so auf das konzentrieren was uns
alle betrifft unsere gesellschaft
unseren zusammenhalt und und die
wirtschaftliche ungleichheit ich glaube
das ist zunächst mal wichtiger wenn wir
das abgearbeitet haben dann können wir
zu den spezial problemen kommen aber
donald trump hat ja gewalt angefacht
werden das am 6 januar gesehen und der
mann ist wirklich brandgefährlich wenn
jemand darf volksverhetzung betreibt
muss man das ein bisschen also dann
haben wir ein ganz spezielles phänomen
ich fühle mich persönlich sehr unwohl
wenn twitter und facebook plötzlich
darüber entscheiden was gefährlich ist
was politiker was ja auch zum teil
gewählte gut donald trump hat nicht
gewonnen aber wurde immerhin von fast 50
prozent der bevölkerung gewählt wenn
twitter darüber entscheidet ob diese
menschen sprechen dürfen oder nicht aber
das kommt ja auch daher dass sie nicht
generell reguliert sind sie konnten ja
eigentlich erst so groß und so mächtig
werden weil sie nicht reguliert waren
weil sie in keine box gepasst haben
keinen vorschrift war auch sie anwendbar
das war eigentlich ein wahnsinns
wettbewerbsvorteil weswegen sie auch so
destruktiv tätig sein konnten und andere
industrien branchen abhängen konnten
aber andere branchen die fantastisch
funktioniert funktioniert nehmen wir die
luftfahrt zum beispiel die war
profitabel für die
luftfahrtgesellschaften wir konnten
billig fliegen und es ist ganz selten
ein flugzeug abgestürzt die luftfahrt
war nicht immer profitabel für
deutschland also die luftfahrt branche
in deutschland würde ich jetzt nicht ein
sehr profitables lag jetzt nochmal ganz
grundsätzlich aber es geht vor allen
dingen darum dass die sehr stark was die
sicherheit angeht und dem
verbraucherschutz reguliert waren und
selten flugzeuge abgestürzt und sie
konnten trotzdem ganz gut wirtschaftlich
operieren und die tech konzerne haben
praktisch überhaupt keine vorschriften
die sie irgendwie in zaum halten und das
ist in keinerlei interesse von uns weil
das verringert den wettbewerb und
geringerer wettbewerb bedeutet im
endeffekt dann irgendwann höhere preise
geringere löhne für die menschen die
dort arbeiten und sie haben die absolute
preis macht das heißt letztendlich
müssen wir alle drauf zahlen also ich
bin ja auch sehr sehr wie sie vermutlich
ja wie sie auch freien wettbewerb und
gegen monopole gegendemo pole ich frage
mich nur wie soll so eine macht statten
gehen weil man ein gesetz schaffen das
eine maximale höhe an umsatz an
börsenwert an angestellten definieren
will also soll der staat wirklich die
eigentümer sind ja die aktionäre
großteils enteignen soll der staat dann
gewissermaßen eine oberaufsicht über die
produkte anführen die ganze angeboten
werden also ich sehe dort schon große
schwierigkeiten wenn sie sagen
entmachten werde es einfach jetzt eine
eine entkernung sozusagen also eine
zerschlagung des testes dass auch der
auch zu nero oder wie soll man die
entmachten im rahmen einer
marktwirtschaft jeder andere industrie
ist reguliert ob wir die pharmaindustrie
nehmen die lebensmittelindustrie das
problem ist dass sie jetzt schon zu groß
geworden sie sind eigentlich zum teil zu
groß um sich selbst zu managen die schau
mir selbst kaum noch durch facebook
möchte gegen hate speech vorgehen also
gegen volksverhetzung und solche dinge
sie kommen mit ihren algorithmen selbst
kaum noch hinterher und sie erinnert
mich sehr an die finanzindustrie von vor
zehn zwanzig jahren die auch immer einen
schritt voraus war und die nachricht
produkte geschaffen hat die sie selbst
bereichert haben und im endeffekt musste
die gesellschaft dann den schaden zahlen
als irgendwann mal was daneben ging und
so ist auch die tech-branche jetzt so
speziell dass wenn man sich selbst
ingenieur ist und diese algorithmen
verstehen kann kommt man kaum noch
hinterher das heißt das ist ein echtes
problem aber deshalb sollte man es jetzt
natürlich noch nicht aufgeben diese
produkte funktionieren ja ehrlich gesagt
auch am besten wenn man sie so benutzt
dass sie eigentlich am schädlichsten
sind brandbeschleuniger her absolut also
wenn man sich mal anschaut was auf
facebook abgibt in kommentarspalten wenn
man sich anschaut wie sich menschen auch
auf youtube radikalisieren und die
algorithmen immer neue inhalte
vorschlagen die natürlich auch alle in
dieselbe kerbe schlagen da wird es auch
einem unheimlich selbst wenn man sich
als als liberaler begreift er eigentlich
die freie marktwirtschaft
betrachtet aber man hat das gefühl dass
es überhaupt keine möglichkeit gibt
einzugreifen weil wir sie auch sehr
treffend sagen die konzerne selbst gar
nicht sehen weil es so eine masse an
menschen so eine masse an daten gibt
fotos videos kommentare die hochgeladen
was soll da habe ich ein ganz spannender
punkt und zwar immer wenn ich irgendwas
hochladen auf instagram zum beispiel
kommen immer und ja nur das wort corona
steht kommt der korona warnhinweis
wirklich bin ich hab schon oft zu mir
dass ich irgendwie ein wort weglassen
und da nicht dieser balken über mein
posting kommt kommt immer da frage ich
mich fühle wenn die das so sensitiv
können vielleicht wollen sie auch gar
nicht jeder hate speech in dem
warnhinweis machen weil wenn das möglich
ist ich habe wirklich viele waren schon
ausprobiert um nicht immer diesen button
dort zu kriegen dann können sie
vielleicht auch hass ist aber leider ein
brandbeschleuniger hast es erfasst eine
größere emotionen als liebe und genauso
in kommentaren geht es mehr los
dementsprechend glaube ich manchmal das
metall so nennt sicherheits facebook
vielleicht auch gar kein interesse hat
komplett 1 von lee network zu werden ich
das und das glaube ich auch beim punkt
corona nur ganz kurz da sind die
offenbar tatsächlich sehr gut darin zu
erkennen und dann auch zu warnen so
haben die oft auch einfach vor absolut
legitime dingen gewahrsam nehmen wir
einmal die labor theorie also die frage
kommt krone aus dem labor und wo hahn
das sagen relativ viele experten
wissenschaftler darauf gibt es hinweise
das wurde von facebook konsequent über
monate hinweg gelöscht dann haben die
das entfernt diese regeln haben sich
haben um verzeihung gebeten aber das
wissenschaftliche stände
wissenschaftliche debatten zensiert
werden von einem unternehmen das ist
doch wahnsinn naja ich also ich gebe
ihnen erst mal grundsätzlich gemacht
diese diese kraken machen einem angst
aber ich habe ein bisschen sorge dass
wissen sie wir haben in deutschland zwar
für einen ganz tapfer anwalt steinhöfel
er ist einer der wenigen der sich mit
facebook und auch youtube und all diesen
diesen tech konzern in deutschland
anlegt wenn mandanten von ihm gesperrt
werden und den kann man nur nachlesen er
zum blog und er hat nicht mal eine
adresse eine zuständige wo er ein
deutsches urteil an youtube oder
facebook zu stellen kann er muss dann
nach irland gehen was eine enorme
verzögerung und auch enormen nachteil
für seine mandanten bedeutet und unsere
politik hier in deutschland kriegt das
nicht mal in facebook und youtube oder
wie es meter dazu zu verdonnern freunde
zustell fähige anschrift bitte ab morgen
in deutschland deswegen sie haben völlig
recht ich fürchte dass es viel zu spät
ja es muss von der politik kommen und
was sie angesprochen haben ist ein
aspekt aber schauen wir uns viele andere
an zum beispiel amazon die dringend vor
in jedem lebensbereich von uns es fing
mal an mit büchern und dann kommerz und
jetzt gehen sie in amerika zumindest
information sowie sind praktisch
online-apotheken sie wollen
finanzdienstleistungen anbieten seit
jahren greifen sie alle unsere daten ab
sie wissen vor dem menschen selbst die
jungen sie sind wie alt sie sind sind
sie schwanger schwul was auch immer
haben diese daten silo übergreifend und
haben damit er auch ein und unter dem
einsatz der künstlichen intelligenz die
immer weiter immer schneller von sich
selbst lernt das heißt die haben einen
so großen wettbewerbsvorteil dass sie
alle konkurrenten die hoch kommen
könnten vom markt verdrängen können oder
sie kaufen sie auf entweder um sie zu
integrieren oder um sie abzuwickeln und
das heißt nicht unterbinden uns kunden
doch gott gedacht nein das ist nicht
okay weil sie erst unterbieten sie alle
preislich weil sie natürlich an viel
günstigen preis anbieten können sie
können ja viel größere mengen abnehmen
so dann kaufe ich erst billig oder
nehmen wir über diesen fahrdienst in new
york war super beliebt war extrem
preiswert wir können die denn so
preiswert diesen service anbieten bis
sie die hälfte der taxifahrer aus dem
business gekegelt haben und schubst dann
gegen die preise auf einmal ich muss
leider reicht es ist schon wieder vorbei
vielen dank dass sie zugeschaut haben
uns schön abend noch bis morgen abend
schön abend
[Musik]